Bradley Martin was in studio you know
with the whole Mighty Mouse thing and
Bradley Martin it's not like um Don King
in this thing I think Bloody elbow
posted Brent shop setting up Bradley
Martin verse Mighty Mouse match not
literally they're both my friends a
Mighty Mouse restored the Bradley
talking about it I hit up mighty I'm
like hey Brad's good dude that's my boy
he's like yeah I'm down to grab one I
was a guy let me know Brad's down she'll
pay for whatever to fly you out and make
it happen but I can get some mats here
at my studio we can go to a real gym is
it going on vacation uh then you might
have something he said something August
11th he's like but we'll figure it out I
was like all right cool that's it it's
not like I'm Dana White sending
contracts promoting this thing don't get
twisted it would be fun to watch I'll
give him that